yb je suis même passé chez toi je n'ai
pas pourrir télé au juste prix or on l'a
déjà passé mais je vais repasser au plus
bas voilà c'était ma première télé chez
toi parce que j'étais tellement fan que
je voulais absolument te rencontrer dès
que j'ai eu 18 ans j'ai voulu rencontrer
philippe risoli de là je vous montrais
pas au bonheur de tous les deux
voulaient tous les deux venus vous aime
faire la même ambiance on va faire des
interviews de carlos à vous faites la
même ambiance que celle que vous mettez
dans le public actuellement carlos
bonjour élite vous venez d'où de carlos
j'avais un de berre l'étang
[Applaudissements]
elle vous a gagné quoi cette semaine car
l'eau j'ai gagné un caméscope way est un
équipement d'équitation
[Applaudissements]